>>> YOU'RE WATCHING DISNEY
MINUS, THE MOVIES DISNEY DOESN'T
PROMOTE AS MUCH.
♪ TALE AS OLD AS '09
TAKES PLACE IN A BAR ♪
♪ PRINCESS FINALLY BLACK
WHY THE PLOT SO WHACK
PRINCESS AND THE FROG ♪
OH, UH-OH.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE I'M SAYING
THIS, BUT I THINK I'VE FALLEN IN
LOVE.
WITH A FROG.
>> I KNOW, IT'S CRAZY, RIGHT?
I'M LIKE THIS FROG, YOU'RE LIKE
THIS PRINCESS.
BUT I GUESS IT'S TRUE WHAT THEY
SAY.
LOVE IS LOVE IS LOVE.
I HOPE I'M NOT BEING TOO
FORWARD, TIANA, BUT WILL YOU
KISS ME?
>> OF COURSE I WILL.
BECAUSE LOVE CONQUERS ALL.
>> EXACTLY.
YOU LOVE ME FOR ME.
YOU DON'T CARE THAT I'M A FROG
AND FROGS DON'T HAVE PENISES.
>> WHAT WAS THAT?
>> IT'S JUST A SCIENTIFIC FACT.
FROGS DON'T HAVE PENS.
AND THAT'S WHY I LOVE YOU.
>> AND THAT'S JUST SOMETHING
EVERYBODY KNOWS?
IT'S ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS
THAT COMES UP WHEN YOU GOOGLE
"FROG PENIS."
YOU KNOW WHAT LET'S JUST KISS
AND GET MARRIED AND WE'LL TACKLE
THE WHOLE NO PENIS THING LATER.
>> SORRY.
JUST -- SO IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
PENIS, WHAT DO YOU HAVE?
>> OH, IT'S EVERY WOMAN'S DREAM.
I GOT BALLS THAT JUST SHOOT
STUFF DIRECTLY ON YOU.
NO PESKY PENIS GETTING IN THE
WAY.
>> OH, WOW.
>> IT'S LIKE THEY ALWAYS SAY.
WHO NEEDS A STRAW WHEN I CAN
JUST THROW THE MILKSHAKE IN YOUR
FACE?
HOW ABOUT THAT KISS?
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW -- I MIGHT
HAVE TO RETHINK THIS A BIT.
>> OH, COME ON.
SIZE DOESN'T MATTER.
>> I THINK IT DOES WHEN IT'S
ZERO.
HOW DO YOU EVEN HAVE SEX?
>> OH, I'LL EXPLAIN IN GREAT
DETAIL.
YOU SEE, I CLIMB ON YOUR BACK
AND I WRAP MY FORELIMBS AROUND
YOUR BODY, THEN I STAY THERE
ABOUT TWO DAYS AND CROAK LOUDLY
IN YOUR EAR UNTIL YOU LAY YOUR
EGGS.
HOW MANY EGGS DO YOU TYPICALLY
LAY?
>> I DON'T LAY EGGS.
>> OH, THAT COULD BE A DEAL
BREAKER.
>> YOU KNOW THIS NEVER CAME UP
WHEN WE DISSECTED FROGS IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
>> WHAT?
>> DR. FACILIER, THE VOODOO
WITCH DOCTOR FROM THIS MOVIE.
>> SO, IF I KISS THIS FROG,
HE'LL TRANSFORM INTO A PRINCE?
>> ONLY IF IT'S TRUE LOVE.
>> UH-HUH?
UH-HUH?
AND WHAT WOULD HAPPEN WITH
HIS -- PENIS?
>> HIS PENIS?
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> WELL, APPARENTLY FROGS DON'T
HAVE THEM.
>> THE HELL?
WELL, THEN, HOW DO THEY --
>> IT JUST SHOOTS UP THE NUTS.
>> ON THE PLUS SIDE, I CAN DO
ORAL FROM LIKE FIVE FEET AWAY.
>> WELL.
I GUESS IF HE CHANGED BACK TO
BEING A HUMAN, HE WOULD GET HIS
PENIS BACK.
>> THEN LET'S DO IT!
LET'S KISS AND JOIN OUR SOULS
FOREVER!
>> AND WHAT IF I DIDN'T HAVE A
PENIS BEFORE?
>> WHAT?
>> I MEAN, AS A HUMAN, BEFORE
THE CURSE.
WHAT IF I, HYPOTHETICALLY, GOT
RIPPED CLEAN OFF AT A BOWLING
ALLEY?
IF SHE KISSED, WOULD IT GROW
BACK?
>> A BOWLING ALLEY?
>> I TRIED TO HUMP THE BALL
RETURN MACHINE, AS A JOKE.
AND THE GEARS SORT OF TORE IT
CLEAN OFF.
>> STOP SAYING CLEAN OFF.
>> IF YOU SAW IT, YOU'D AGREE.
>> YOU ARE A WEIRD FROG, DUDE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HELL IS
GOING ON WITH YOU.
BUT AT LEAST YOU'RE A PRINCE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THE PRINCE OF NEWARK,
NEW JERSEY.
>> OKAY.
I'M -- I'M OUT.
>> YEAH, EVEN FOR VOODOO, THIS
IS MESSED UP.
♪ IT'S NOT EASY BEING GREEN
IT'S ABOUT TIME I INTRODUCED
MYSELF.
MY NAME RAYMOND.
BUT EVERYBODY CALLS ME RAY.
I'M THE CAJUN FIREFLY IN THE
MOVIE.
WHICH THAT'S WRONG.
AND CRITICALLY, I MIGHT BE JUST
ABOUT THE WORST DISNEY CHARACTER
EVER CREATED.
DISNEY ASKED KIDS LEAVING THE
MOVIE, "WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
OLD RAY?"
EVERY KID SAY, "KILL HIM.
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE RAY NO
PLACE, NO WHERE, NEVER AGAIN."
ON TIME, THEY INVITE OLD RAY TO
ONE OF THEY CHARACTER BREAKFASTS
OVER AT THE DISNEY WORLD.
THEY GIVE KIDS METAL BATS, SAY
"GO GET HIM.
GO KILL OLD RAY TILL HE'S DEAD!"
BUT DON'T WORRY, AT THE END OF
THE DAY, OLD RAY GOING TO BE
JUST FINE.
AAYOUR HONOR!
>> THE END.